Look at him.
Looks pretty stacked.
Good looking kids.
A thick dude.
He's a short dude in that.
He's probably walking around at
more than 45 I would say it's more than 40 dude,
he's so short.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I still think he's more than a hundred years.
That's a tough life.
If you're that short and you're not an Olympic champion,
right?
Like I was looking at him the other day in a video,
my Goddamn,
he's dying.
What does e five two five two,
five,
three.
I'm only five inches away from that.
I'm barely five inches.
That's a lifetime.
Five inches.
And what's money?
They would pay to have five inches.
They do pay.
Do you ever see what they do?
They stretch your bones where they break them and then extend them.
Do you know how crazy you have to be to get your shins extended?
They cut your shins so they saw into you and then they put this metal brace all
around you like a halo brace and then you crank it a little bit of click,
click,
click.
You have a couple inches taller.
C'Mon Bro.
For what?
So so it's an ego thing.
No.
So you can get laid.
I was watching this documentary on Chinese guys.
This guy was like,
he had these braces on his leg and he's like my girlfriend,
she,
no,
she wouldn't marry me because I'm too short,
but I'll come to her and I'm going to be over five feet tall for the first time
to use it under five feet tall.
Get another girl.
Fuck that Hoe.
It's hard to get a girl when you're four nine.
The biggest problem is if you have a short dick.
Yeah,
but the biggest problem is if you're four nine D,
they don't want to see your Dick.
Oh Jesus.
Look at this guy.
He went from five or six inches.
Five,
six to six foot.
Okay,
let me see this.
Oh God.
He was a thickie on the low gain.
Six inches from stretching.
It's fucking bones out.
Let me see what it says there.
How unhappy do you have to be with your body?
Go up there.
Nip,
Tuck,
grow.
Five foot six inch man underwent astonishing leg lengthening procedure because
he wanted to be six foot tall.
Oh,
he started at five six and he got up to six feet tall.
Geez us.
But how fucking damaging is that?
Not Well,
how we see the procedure in which both legs are broken then slowly stretched
bears more than a little resemblance to medieval torture.
Let me see what this fucking guy did do is,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
It has to be some mental health issue.
Yeah.
Oh,
the Trent.
Well,
maybe if you wanted to really play football,
the trend for Ling Leong limb lengthening surgery swept China where minimum
heights are often quoted on personal adverts and job advertising says the
country opened up to the west a decade ago.
Look at that fucking thing on his leg,
man.
Oh my God.
So his w w we're looking at here,
it looks like they stick cut an inch out of his bone,
but then they have this bar that runs through it.
So that's his femur man,
dude,
that the leg bone,
that's not even his shin.
How do you think he's going to feel when he's 70 that can't be good for wanting
to be five inches taller.
Dude,
get a skill.
You know what chicks dig over height skill man.
Funny.
Get a fucking ah,
650 leg lengthening procedures in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
Not all to remedy deformity.
Some of them to remedy deformities,
which make sense.
There's some,
how long do you think it takes for them to fucking recover from something like
that?
A lifetime.
Oh,
they kind of height dysphoria.
So it's sorta like Anorexia with their height.
It's a mental disorder.
Oh,
it's one of the few psychiatric disorders that you can actually cure with the
knife says the surgeon oof what that says.
The surgeon trying to sell this bullshit.
Doctor uses the term knife or you don't really use it on a knife,
bro.
Not you have a scalpel by night going to that guy.
What I can cure what the saw it costs 85 grand.
Look at it says he does here it's surgery is not for the faint hearted.
The leg bone is broken into the doctor.
Then implants a state of the art telescopic rod into the cartilage of the bone,
which then pulls it apart very gradually.
One millimeter a day.
New living bone grows along it to fill the gap and muscles or nerves.
The arteries is skin also renew themselves.
The cost is prohibitive.
$85,000 takes at least three months to complete.
Grueling physical therapy is essential.
Ah,
look at that one.
Look at the gap and his fucking leg.
Look how big that gap,
but you can play in any lower.
It's just sport walking up that kind of leg kicking him.
Yeah,
I was just thinking that.
Oh,
imagine if he decides to do Moitai.
I betcha his um,
like where your leg is vulnerables changed,
right?
Dude,
if your girls geometry core leg is like,
if you,
if your leg is a certain,
like if your bones are a certain wit,
I would imagine there's like a,
like it all makes sense pretty much in terms of like mathematics,
like how long your knee is or how long your femur is.
It would be a certain thickness,
but then if you spread it out,
it's like the thickness of a shorter one,
but now it's long.
It's probably more bonus safe,
like stilt to make me tell our community.
I just found,
oh wow.
There's a whole trick induction to leg lengthening and frequently asked
questions.
Holy Shit,
there's only 30 posts though,
dude,
this one's got 300 posts.
This is 3000 posts down here till I die,
or have a ton though.